from the docks of dover hard hit by this
tale
the focus shifted today to the seat of
parliamentary power
the government said it would force piano
to change course today we heard how
i am today announcing a package of nine
measures that will force them to
fundamentally rethink their decision i
can announce the house our intention to
give british ports new statutory powers
to refuse access to regular ferry
services which do not pay their crew the
national minimum wage
we had expected direct laws to enforce
minimum wage on these ships but there
were other measures too more
compensation for workers fired without
process
and moves against this man the potential
disqualification of peter hebelthwaite
as a company director
but there were notable emissions not
least a prior promise of legal action
the government's reluctance to use every
tool at this disposal to force them to
change course is bewildering
no prosecution has been taken despite
the prime minister's announcement last
week and the deadline to act to protect
these workers is tomorrow
this will send a clear message to the
maritime industry
it's a deadline that weighs heavy on
sacked workers watching on there's
nothing here that will restore their
jobs but are they pleased with what they
heard
no nowhere near there's
they've not really done anything if
they've threats and things but you know
tomorrow's the final day and where are
we we're no closer to
getting our jobs back getting
us back on those ships
many are now saying this is becoming one
of the most infamous incidents in the
history of industrial relations
certainly it's rare to have a case that
so unites all parties and spurs the
government into action so quickly it may
not help all the sac staff this time but
it will change the future for workers in
this sector
but changing the future won't feel like
enough in the present there will be
questions about enforcement of the new
rules here and why this crippled brand
was not punished further
helenan smith sky news in dover